is here oh my gosh i'm going with
three thousand jesus okay of course i'm
coming for for you of course
harder hacked of course i'm here at your
command
give me some rating please okay let's
just play here
maybe i can even greens out 3200s
today why not
i think this is the line i played
against anish
so what do i do like bishop c4
i think so
probably i don't know i'm probably okay
one
hmm queen e2
somehow this is not so simple for black
well uh obviously this is equal but
i think i even tried to play this
against anish but it was a quick draw
hmd5 here is one
so you know let's play okay maybe okay
d1
won't be bad b3
now i'm going to take on f6 at some
point and take on d5
so now maybe we should be six and bishop
d4 also maybe h3
is another useful move to be played
queen e6 this is almost a blunder of
some material but almost is not enough
where is he going to did i take on f6
right now and then do i play c4 after
now let's still try bishop d4 i don't i
don't see the point in what is he doing
probably because there is no point
so c4 is maybe a little bit premature
i'm a little bit making my bishop
maybe at least a bit too passive
okay so now i take let's try to trade
more
oh this is a bad one you guys screaming
five in the end
yeah that's that's a misplay speaking
you know in in hearthstone's
terminology
okay this is uh going i mean okay if not
if no one wanders a lot
with one move it should likely be a draw
but
let's see
that's a bold move
i have to calculate something but i
don't want to
help me please free me from this you
know
responsibility okay queen d4 should be
healthy move after check i go to
h2
uh all right
okay let's go here well that's a blunder
that's a blunder that's how my rating
increases guys
that's how my rating increases probably
we repeat twice very classy
and that's how and that's how you flag
yeah
you repeat position without any
necessity
but then your opponent loses some
priceless seconds
okay now it's a mating net around his
king
so what oh let's play queen f4 if he
goes to an end game then
then why not
okay take here
okay i think i take
yes plus eight
i feel so good like having plus eight
out of this
after this game impressive
i'm so proud